what do you think will be the tipping
point by which we can restructure our
education system and the way that we
think about educating young people to
create a worldwide community of free
thinkers thanks for that question I was
very lucky I went to a pretty
exceptional International School in
Venezuela for high school I quite like
my legatee and and for elementary school
I went to a Montessori School which
again is all about building the
curriculum around the kids passions and
interests a lot of successful people
once a month of sorry school there's
something to that
my mother is probably the greatest
teacher alive not that I'm biased I was
blessed to have her actually as my
literature teacher 10th 11th and 12th
grade all my friends you know loved her
and loved me because I was Linda's son
it's pretty groovy but so I was very
lucky but I'm privy to the fact that not
everybody is that lucky some friends of
mine out of Dubai of all places who run
innovation for the Jemez international
schools have launched a new company I
think it might be a nonprofit it's
called the aw academy or Academy yeah
and they're working on creating a
curriculum that uses non traditional
modes of education such as cosmic Wonder
and curiosity and they have all the all
the buzzwords they were using a lot of
shots of awe in the curriculum they're
working with singularity University to
teach kids about exponential thinking so
that they can dream bigger than ever and
back up those dreams with exponential
technologies so it kind of ticks all
those boxes so that's our little grain
in the sand I did some videos for them
I'm kind of an informal advisor so I
would point you to aw Academy or AutoCAD
imme and see what they're up to I also
imagine people like Ken Robinson
interesting initiatives in that space if
it was up to me you know I feel like
when I was in high school I used to host
these salons in my house on Friday
nights and full disclosure we got stoned
and watched videos no alcohol but um the
point of these sessions I learned very
quickly in following the tradition of
Charles Baudelaire and his hashish
parties was that if you bring a bunch of
intellectuals and you create a sort of
sunken living room environment where
everybody is forced to face each other
and then you get them mildly intoxicated
very interesting ideas start to flow
very interesting exchanges start to be
had you start to notice quirks and
details and nuances of conversation that
only happened when you're present and
facing each other and slightly altered
and I remember that after we did that
first phase one we take everybody
upstairs to my home theater room which I
was really neurotic about as a kid and I
had a special chair with something
installed in it called a tactile sound
transducer that would turn Watts from
the amp of music into vibrations on the
chair and then I had the speaker's and
then it had like all these scenes for
movies already and of course I'd make
sure that my friends were baked as hell
and then I'd be like sit there and I'm
gonna show you this scene and you may
think what the hell is stupid teenaged
owner
I was giving them profound educational
experiences because I was cracking them
open and giving them off and all wakens
curiosity all increases empathy and
compassion or boost creativity acts as
an anti-inflammatory and again it you
stay in the halo after the fact so I'm
not advocating giving students pot but
I'm saying the pot is a metaphor a
stand-in for modules and or techniques
and technologies that can alter the
consciousness of the kid maybe it's just
moving around maybe get up from the
[ __ ] desk and dance until they're in
an altered state you know maybe it's
teaching the meditation in class you
know I mean this is
thank you you're welcome Ola my question
is about this advice very common that
you should um get rid of technology from
time to time avoid technology yeah
getting interruption you think
technology is part or source or a
contributor to or excite you or
depression look I would actually say
it's not technology per se it's bad bad
practices you know we kind of need a set
of best practices for everything it's
like we don't get on a plane unless the
pilot is really well trained I also have
a broader definition of technology I
know what you're asking you're asking if
like our incessant use of smart phones
as distracting us from the president so
on and so forth but like you asking me a
question is employing a wireless
technology known as language where you
encode the contents of your
consciousness and the symbolic thing
like would you transmit it through time
and space I receive it I decide for it
like it's a really good technology for
the most part when used correctly but
but language can also be weaponized
right a language can be used for hate
speech propaganda language and eloquence
were used by a human cancer known as
Hugo Chavez to [ __ ] Venezuela that
guy was an elegant piece of [ __ ] but he
was an elegant speaker you know and so
language can be weaponized all
technologies can be weaponized all
technologies are a double-edged sword
right you can use fire to cook your food
without cooking human beings wouldn't
have evolved past stage one we used to
spend all our time chewing once we could
cook our food we could stay full for
long enough to develop arts and crafts
and culture so without cooking there
wouldn't be us without fire there
wouldn't be us but fire also burns the
villages so I guess the answer to your
question is
yeah technology can be used in piss-poor
ways but without social media
none of you would know about my videos
none of us
we hear having this conversation
thousands of people wouldn't have gotten
inspired by the work that I've done in
the work that so many others have done
so the answer is and always will be it's
a double-edged sword these are just
amplifiers it's how we use it it counts
you know thank you one thing I've seen
that you've been able to do was kind of
make an objective formula about you know
how to obtain it and even bring it about
in yourself almost like the man
have you ever yourself or maybe somebody
with similar qualities like yourself
into an MRI machine or some other form
of objective measure mm-hmm to see what
looks like I haven't I really I would
love to do that most of my experiences
and MRI machines have been fueled by
hypochondriacal panic thankfully
everything's okay but yeah but no that
would be awesome wouldn't it yeah what
if they're like oh actually a third eye
opening you can see it in the scanner I
would be great bro I haven't done it I'd
be very curious to they have done that
with freestyle rappers and comparing
them to rappers and we're reciting
memorize lyrics I don't know I don't
know they just lying down and they were
like that's right here we go
but but what was interesting is that
those that were that were improvising so
then they were in flow maybe not an off
but like a precursor to is definitely
flow yeah just the two just the two
don't worry but they found that the the
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex which is
just science jargon for the inner critic
shuts down so what's interesting is
during flow you don't use more of your
brain you use less but more efficiently
it seems or in a way that serves us
better the aperture focuses as Jamie
wheel says and so isn't that interesting
you know and it's it's less it's stuff
that shuts down that results in these
flow States would you believe I know
when again i OCD so mike is it
connecting because i do you like
patterns
[Music]
yeah I think that it's like glasses full
or glass is empty depending on your
filters and your lenses you see with
your lenses usually through your lenses
but you don't see the lenses themselves
if you saw the lenses themselves you
might be able to change the lenses that
has to do with like interpretive
frameworks and like changing your
interpretive frameworks in a way that
serves you
I remember once reading was like New Age
horoscope weird book called pronoia but
the idea was this cool message pronoia
is the antidote to paranoia
so paranoia is you connect the dots and
everything is against you as your
conclusion
paranoia is you connect the dots and
everything is serving you which
interpretation would you choose and so
do we have agency over that
interpretation
there's certainly predisposition you
know past trauma can make you look at
everything that's happening in the
future is dangerous right trauma makes
the past over determine the present and
conjure up a future that becomes
identified with death or chaos right
David Lentz and says that bad trips on
drugs are just exaggerated versions of
the same thing right a pre-existing fear
you had about the experience over
determines the effects of the drug and
conjures up a future of oh I'm going
crazy or I'm going to die it's just an
amplified exaggeration of what we do
when we're already anxious which is
formed by past experiences but you can
change those past experiences by
changing your interpretive frameworks
one of my most popular videos was can
you change the past and the idea was you
know epigenetics has to do with the
effects that experiences have on your
physiology experience shapes biology but
let's say you do an MDMA therapy session
like they're like okay great great so
there's an organization called a
multidisciplinary Association of
psychedelic studies which just got
granted phase 3 clinical trials
designated breakthrough therapy using
MDMA to help people with treatment
resistant PTSD yeah so people who've
been in war and are not
medication so what they do this
particular technology puts people in
what they call the optimal arousal zone
so it quiets the amygdala which is the
fear response which is trying to protect
you from impending doom quiets that
while boosting activity in the frontal
cortex so you can think rationally about
things then it simultaneously engages
you because it's a methamphetamine while
simultaneously making you feel relaxed
as you're more engaged they call that
the Goldilocks it's just like planet
Earth just close enough to the Sun not
too much and that optimal arousal zone
is great for cognitive reframing it's
like you can think back about the
experience you can be like okay that
sucked
that was one isolated experience it
doesn't condemn me to have future
experiences like that and that sort of
realignment and cognitive reframing and
rhe patterning of the memory changes the
past experience in the sense that it
changes the physiological effects that
it's having on your present moment so
maybe you're not getting the cortisol
anymore you're not getting the anxiety
secreting chemicals anymore and so
you're effectively cured so I would say
that that changing those interpretive
frameworks and exercising agency over
that and realizing that you can do that
is the best intervention thank you oh
yeah are you Sarah hey how are you yes
finally yes
so um question after 15 years of working
I noticed that there was something going
on I was like I'm coming from hell why
is this happening why is everybody more
into creating content out of there
lives trying to uplift their egos and
make themselves look like they're
perfect out there while they're not
taking care of their lives their health
their family their kids all of these
things we're spending money on you know
looking good for Instagram we're
spending our lives going to places that
probably we don't even want to go there
yeah but somebody else planned you know
and we want to be there because of the
freaking picture so what's your
perception towards the negative impact
that social media has done on us as
humans human being and what and how
would you transform influencers into any
actors hmm
well the thing is weird
social beings that in order to survive I
made you go back to when we lived in
small groups in the savannahs of Africa
a hundred thousand years ago like we
live in these small packs and survival
required being included in the group
because if you were ostracized from the
group you were alone in the lion ate you
so you realize that we have a lineage
that requires us to be liked to survive
and that ancient wiring plays out with
something as trivial as obsessing over
likes on Instagram it's like if you're
not accepted or liked you risk social
being socially pushed aside and by the
way social isolation is the quickest way
to go mad human beings cannot live alone
they go crazy right we consciousness
only exists through the mutual mental
modeling of us against other people like
we mirror each other constantly right
it's like that hold of the Cooley line I
am not who I think I am I'm not what you
think I am I am I think you think I am
all right I make a model of what your
consciousness is and then they can make
a model of what your consciousness is
modeling of me is and then I try to be
that person or control who I think you
think I am like we do that all the time
that mutual self modeling and mirroring
is the essence way the thing is it's I
don't want to use a nasty word but it's
metastasized with social media it's like
again tools and technologies amplify
pre-existing patterns and belief systems
that we have so it's like we
used to try to be liked among the 20 or
so in our little tribe to protect
ourselves from lying at night and being
liked was important being cooperative
with the group was important because
otherwise you got a you know pushed
aside so now we act compulsively with
social media but it comes from that same
place
so the solution obviously is just
awareness right like oh we can learn
because we can learn now we have new
information we can watch our own actions
and modify those actions which is not to
say that these tools aren't designed to
create compulsive behavior rather than
thoughtful behavior they are because
there's a business model attached to
that and I understand like we have a
capitalist system business models
monetization is part of the game but it
there seems to be an awakening now in
Silicon Valley I mean the conversation
is being had you know we all know
tristan harris and all these other
people who are having an awakening and i
think that's how it works right
we're like innovative and creative and
we build these marvelous tools then
we'll get really excited and then we use
them in a shitty way for a little while
looking we've course-correct
and I think we're course correcting you
know I'm an optimist you look at the
long-term trends into the macro trends
there's always improvement even when
there's not there is the more you zoom
out so I'm sorry I'm so sorry
now my question more is view is your
encounters with physical practices sure
the first physical embodiment ya know
embodiment is huge one of my favorite
places to hang out especially the summer
is Amsterdam and it's because you don't
even think it but your baseline modality
is movement on bicycle all day every day
to do anything from the most
insignificant errand to a full day
adventure you're my friend calls it
balance in motion or the unbalancing
axis it's like oh if
you move you're good if you stop moving
it falls you know the best flow states
ever are cannabis in combination well I
said friends said 20 minutes of aerobic
exercise a shot of espresso in a joint
but I would add to that I would add to
that motion like motion particularly
human propelled motion but dude like
riding a bicycle like some of the
greatest experience of my life have been
riding bikes and Amsterdam with my
friends while slightly smiley Copenhagen
we had a similar experience I had an
experience in South Africa last year
which was astonishing because we were on
the back of the safari truck sunset
Golden Hour you know in motion in an
omnidirectional way - because those
things go off the road so it's not even
like you're tied to the pattern of the
road you're just you're going in every
in any direction and I guess that's not
fully embodied but at least you're in
motion and it was just sublime also
because the changing landscape and the
changing speed at which the world comes
at you keeps you tethered to the moment
and doesn't let you spiral off into your
own thoughts especially if you're prone
to anxiety and so that's that's that's a
huge one - thanks for your question man
thank you and just very quickly I want
to extend a special thank you to all of
you guys for being here tonight you guys
have been wonderful and a special thanks
to my partners on the tour mr. Ben
Jacobson who's been over there making
sure that all the video stuff works
Thank You Ben appreciate you
and of course Josh Dawson and Ingrid
thank you guys
pull thank you thank you to our AV team
for hustling last minute we were having
crazy technical difficulties earlier
like crazy you know like Murphy's Law
like though this [ __ ] wasn't working
gonna projector whether I wasn't nearly
and the thing is I mean I could do a
lecture without the videos but I feel
like the videos are the work and I just
fill the space between with my live
remarks but I want to be able to show
you what I do otherwise it wouldn't be
the same so thank you guys for hustling
to make that work and thank you to the
city of may Miami the police department
for providing the security as well and
by the way the reason for that is a
slight you know we did this tour in
Canada we didn't need metal detectors in
Canada because in Canada people don't
have guns right America is weird like
that
it's messed up man no so that's why we
had the extra line so sorry about that
but wanted to keep you guys all safe
right thank you everybody
[Applause]